you when welcome to this video he gives
is the opponent and well it's kind of
it's kind of funny if you know that your
first to Moosa GC and Bishop g2 it's an
easy life you won't have to thank for
the first four seconds okay what do we
get probably some kind of English he
says i watch your youtube videos why I'm
really too bad with sometimes I just
wanted to say thanks it took me 20
seconds at the wrong button there okay
so we got a symmetrical English here
yeah this is a an interesting oops wrong
thought you have to take first is that
really okay let's do this and take one
c5 how I might know I'm not just winning
a pawn here or does he get it back
so go into a 5 mm maybe just be should
be to hear that looks simple yeah let's
do that make sure I can check with the
bishop you cannot take clearly not but
it term it feels right not sure what he
what you should do now very just develop
yam just continue with development and
see if you can get the pawn back
somewhat somewhat lay down just here or
yeah let's just go right or three okay
so I was thinking let's wait I can take
okay I have to take first and then I can
decide what to do if you go with rook
cakes i have ruka one Queen 85 Bishop a
three wins the exchange and I will keep
my porn queen takes I have I thought
Bishop a one but it can actually take
one c5 yeah he has that but green before
I can go deform there's nothing wrong
with that i think just hear voice bishop
a6 a problem I wonder Bishop a1 Quincy
five rupee 898 it looks much better
developed
okay but it's a call let's let's let's
keep that it's really just a pawn so
like here
yes bit of activity there how the pawn
I'm not sure if it's enough but I cannot
like just simply convert the porn let's
I don't don't see that night-night time
no didn't don't do that some light
maneuver like Knight a5 see quad so what
was possible maybe yeah I wonder if I
should go with 3m it weakens d3 quite a
bit but stabilizes my center or a form
just pushing a 45 that's actually
interesting let's do that because 95
becomes an option yeah that was right i
think doing the aggressive way here he
has rupee too but i am attacking f6
first so he cannot just go look bit too
i think
oh we actually does and okay so I'm
taking here and Quincy three Roxy to
intermediate a check or if I know that
that's not so bright let's just do this
and then take one f6 and I'm an exchange
up you know mighty Scotty's got some
activity still so d5 yeah I have to have
to play actively here push the things
forward here possibly the sea porn is my
my winner d for was also under attack so
should be right to push that forward oh
that's a good move probably okay let's
take Bishop cheeks and what now I
looking for actually I didn't see that
move for beforehand but I can do that so
it wasn't a good move but I saw that
really late
yeah you just loses that re 5 and maybe
you can go if I hear actually I'm just
seeing that e 5d is 66 that's still
possible bit of a hidden resource
resource at the right way to pronounce
it 'if I've if I was not clear at all
yeah he found it
ah crazy
time morning
I can might go back he just go back okay
so let's let's do something else yeah
let's return the exchange here for
control that said was good i think i
should have pushed c6 you've been better
wow what am I doing here nonsense
unbelievable Queen B 1 bar what a joke
from that position I was stupid I should
cancel that just totally idiotic I just
why did I move that so quickly it's just
totally totally idiotic here you just he
can just resign the game of course okay
so that was that was a really bad way to
do it whatever I think the worst thing
is it was really okay game I think I
played it well and yeah even that is a
decent idea for Luke see for later cam
the engine wants to take and play King
age one is usually very cold-blooded
okay that's better than my move but
that's not easy to play for a human
player you still feel kind of feels
weird on the D file but okay this is
just a very clear wind what's a look-see
one is good yeah i just i know it was
mindless just playing those those moves
quickly
Luke see one just have to cover the back
rank and stupid I don't know I just
played this too quickly thinking this is
so I don't know I didn't think I just
played key look before it's just ending
the game gee I'm just lost oh that was
stupid very stupid plane yeah other than
that I think I think I did it all right
and the opening you just blundered this
pawn black has to check first this is
just losing a porn for nothing yeah yeah
that's the worst part of it as I
actually think I played it at played a
good game here and then I'm blundering
it away just very simply okay thanks for
watching